hello everyone and welcome to debates
live broadcasts principles and
performance characteristics of automated
platelet counting methods presented by
Donald Wright's scientific affairs
manager u.s. hematology Abbott
Diagnostics I'm Alexis Krause of lab
rats and I will be our moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is brought to you by lavage and
sponsored by Abbott Diagnostics now
let's get started
before I begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into that ask a question box and click
on the send button well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support tab found at
the top right of the presentation window
will report your problem by clicking on
the answer a question box located on the
far left of your screen this
presentation is educational and the
software's continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits I'd like
to now introduce our presenter Donald
Wright Donald Wright is a global
scientific affairs manager for Abbott
Diagnostics hematology Donald has worked
in clinical laboratory services and the
commercial hematology industry for the
entirety of his career he has served in
a variety of roles including automated
hematology supervisor educational
coordinator scientific marketing
scientific liaison flow cytometry and
cellular analysis specialists in several
managerial positions his research and
publications include applications of
monoclonal antibodies and flow cytometry
characterization of new hematology
product performance and development of
novel hematology assays and markers in
his current role donald provides
scientific support for healthcare
professionals and serves as a scientific
resource to various functions including
R&D business development
strategic operations and other
departments Donald is a member of
several organizations including American
associates of clinical chemists
International Society for laboratory
hematologists in the American Society of
Clinical pathologist for a complete
biography on Donald please click on this
photo in the top left corner of your
screen welcome Donald you may now begin
your presentation
hello today we're going to start a
presentation on principles and
performance characteristics of automated
pet accounting methods this is a web
series affiliated with lab roots
disclosure statement the speaker program
is sponsored by and on behalf of Abbott
Diagnostics the content of this
presentation is consistent with all
applicable FDA requirements
today's hematology analyzer analyzers
utilize various methods for enumerated
platelets including electrical impedance
light scatter fluorescence and
analogical recognition with monoclonal
antibodies
approach is generally produce an
accurate for the count
the majority of samples
we all knows circulating abnormalities
have been shown to negatively affect the
reliability of reported results
the impact on quality varies depending
on the specific interference and
technology used to determine the plaited
count so today in this webinar different
principles used for counting platelets
and the effect of circulating
interferences on the performance of each
method will be reviewed
you
max Schultz and Julius visa zero have
been recognized as the first two to
describe clay boats and their
association with hemostasis Schultz
described the morphology of platelets
and then they were several times smaller
than red cells these are zero further
observe but it's freely circulate in the
blood
however when subject to an influence
that leads to thrombosis
they'd here to one another to form an
accumulation stick to each other
you
so platelets or thrombocytes are
nucleated
discoid cell formed by the cytoplasmic
fragmentation of bone marrow
megakaryocytes megakaryocytes are the
end maturational stage of speak of a
sequence which starts with a
differentiation of a player potential
stem cell this process mediated by
stimulation principally by the
glycoprotein hormones gombo cleaner tto
deploy a potential cells differentiate
to become morphologically and amia
logically distinct cells commit to a
platelet lineage these maturational
changes include respectively the mega
carrier blasts grow megakaryocytes the
megakaryocytes
you can see on the slide
cells reach the mega carrier blast
actually loses LeFort of capacity and
starts its maturation process
megha carrier police is this unique way
of maturation it does not occur any
other cell lineage the cell multiplies
nuclear material within the same cell
which is called end of mitosis or in
other words nuclear division without
cell division
depending on the physiological need of
new platelets and then mitosis stops the
formation of platelets again
to process the cytoplasmic cutting each
megakaryocyte is able to generate
between 2,000 and 5,000 platelets which
uncirculated in the peripheral blood for
about five to ten days or become cooled
in the spleen
pilots themselves play a key role in
primary hemostasis the initial stage
involves plated adhesion in this process
the play that's come into contact with
the negatively charged surfaces of the
exposed and the filial of a damaged
tissue and adhere to them as you can see
in the diagram
processes principally mediated through
interaction between platelets surface
glycoproteins particularly gp1 B von
Willebrand's factor in collagen fibers
of those sub and athelia
once platelets have become stuck to the
collagen and ago a series of
morphological and biochemical changes
which constitute a secondary phase known
as platelet activation
mediated through clevage of membrane
phospholipids biochemical signals begin
a sequence of changes during which
intracellular calcium levels rise
neglect of protein to b38 complex is
expressed in the surface of a platelet
and then these biochemical changes are
associated with distinct morphological
changes rather than remaining discoid
the activated platelets become more
spherical but a distinct the irregular
pseudopod being projected from their
surface and once activated the plates
begin to form a template in which the
blood coagulation processes at life
this process of platelet activation also
initiates release of secretion of power
powerful secondary aggregating agents
from the plated granule the release have
plated agonist like ADP and others
causes propagation of the process which
is platelet aggregation as we can see on
the bottom diagram
during activation exposed glycoprotein
to be and the three three a complex on
the extended pseudopods cosplay that's
defined together and basically to form
the fibrin clot
the platelet count has become an
accepted part of the automated blood
count the clinical value plated counting
is a critical aspect of patient
diagnosis and treatment monitoring and
demonstrating of normal platelet counts
and subjects tested part of a wellness
check for valued and important as part
of a priest surgical screening process
recorded references reference ranges for
the pet account of normal subjects that
would be fall in the hundred and fifty
to 400,000 range demonstration of
thrombocytopenia or thrombocytosis or
valuable if not specific findings in the
context of disease beck toast
so when our play that counts performed
this previously mentioned
screening CBC done routinely and again
as a general wellness indicator and also
for preoperative screening disease
monitoring to determine trend in
patients with abnormal blood accounts
there are secondary to disease process
therapeutic monitoring increases or
decreases input accounts are important
when monitoring patients such on chemo
chemotherapy or other process monitoring
and of course play the transfusion
ultimately assessing the severity of
from the site of tinea reciprocally risk
of severe bleeding and/or the need for
by the transfusion
today the disorders are most commonly
cause of bleeding can be divided in
essentially two categories related to
play that number and/or the platelet
function in this table below you can see
under play that number most often
associated thrombocytopenia
give me two types of issues from
congenital and one acquired
in general categories you see things
such as make a carrier CITIC hypoplasia
homicide opinio absent radii and this
got Aldrich syndrome which is very rare
congenital disease certainly the
acquired reasons include immuno
thrombocytopenia from a robotic
thrombocytopenic purpura di C infections
splenomegaly from our suppression of
infiltration aplastic anemia
function in general there's glands
disease Bernard so--yes which is very
rare and storage granule defects and of
course you can have always acquired
budget functions associated with
medication drugs uremia
myeloproliferative disorders which is
really a from a set of pharma psychosis
and those associated with multiple
myeloma
further accounting technologies and
methods
the technologies and methods include the
following manual phase microscopy and
smear estimates are considered to be
direct methods of Plata County the
impedance plate account which is
routinely used in laboratory as well as
optical plate accounting which can
include such things as through optical
angle light scatter fluorescence and
multi angle light scatter
French method currently by the ICS H
which is the International Council for
standards and hematology utilizes the
monoclonal approach using CD 41 and CD
61 testing for the GP 3 a and GP to be
site located on the flavor
of course there are single platform
approaches using just the amino plated
of CD 61
face contrast microscopy
this was the
reference method by the ICS H for many
years and it involves using a new Bower
chamber to see on the screen and is a
graduated chamber that will be filled
with a sample solution and when looking
through the microscopic objective you
can see the group 3 gridlines that isn't
the neubauer
and you'll notice in the very center
there is five distinct regions that we
count plate it the red cells are lysed
with the Dewan and then that chamber is
charged and the microscope is then
counts all five windows and then using
various calculations we can determine
the absolute plate accounts
another method is a qualitative play
that estimates
as often used with an automated system
Flags the pivot count
continuation about 10 years of the
unified product which was used to help
assist us and making a quick dilution
and performing the manual it accountants
we saw on the previous slide in lieu of
this discontinuation want to play this
had to reassess how they do plated
estimates and now use this as their
alternate technology for plated
conformation when the automated system
fails to provide account
however at very low levels the
coefficient variation in this high and
may result increased discordant with the
analyzer result published by Anna's on
check back in 1978
one of the only studies that the is in
publication indicates that the CDs can
be as high as 50 percent from the level
of play the counters at twenty seven
thousand and twenty two twenty three
percent when it's between 65 100 out
unfortunately this is what a lot of
laboratories have to resort to when
there is no longer when there is a flag
automated count presented to them
next the CMP displayed account
penis by accounting this for
use a semi-automated method and
subsequently used in automated cell
counters pretty much from the middle of
the 1970s forward
Oh of impedance counting as a passage of
cells suspended in a known solution
through a small detection orifice or the
aperture
daily use serves as an electrolyte
solution to which a constant electrical
turn is maintained between two
electrodes the cells flow through the
orifice they impede the electrical
current and resistance is detected the
detection of discrete resistance commits
any of the event the magnitude of that
resistant pulse we use to estimate the
volume of that event
you
one of the known limitations of the
who's counting is a potential for a
phenomenon called recirculation or eddy
current effect which can cause a false
increase in the cell count
this phenomena is shown in these
diagrams one on the left you can see the
cells passing through the one on the
right what actually happens is when a
cell is located to the edge of the
orifice of the aperture and actually
recirculate for based on its flow path
go back into the detection zone and be
counted again
this can falsely elevated by the count
and we have to be very aware of this
various approaches to resolve
artifact have been applied dimension
instrument manufacturers use lateral
flow of reagents suite already counted
cells away from that detection zone
around that orifice of the aperture
other manufacturers use a plate both to
the orbits which ensures that any cell
recirculation that takes place will be
removed from that detection zone these
devices are often cold after their
inventor in this case at the Vaughn
Barrens plate
another alternative that you see in this
diagram below makes use of hydrodynamic
focusing this technique employs a sheath
of fast-moving fluid that guides and
confined the selfs tension and targeted
through the orifice the aperture
ensuring that during analysis cells are
continuously propelled forward through
and Beyond the orifice and therefore
away from the impedance detection zone
one further advantage of using hydrogen
focusing is that focuses ourselves on
the very center of that force
you
in this diagram you can see the
resulting impedance histogram the image
located on the far left is a typical
image of a normal plate account
the one in the middle you can see by the
line on the right-hand side which is
considered the upper threshold of where
pilots should end and our VC should
begin an overlap region most likely in
this case due to macrocytic thrombocytes
the far right actually shows shows or
indicates maybe a mixed population of
some red cell fragments or perhaps some
large fibers in any case the two on the
right indicate that we have a problem
with the pipe account and most likely
the result will be flagged and will have
to be reconfirmed by alternate
technologies
next mess I'd like to discuss
related account optical methods work on
the principle that diluted sample
suspensions pass through a flow cell
optically clear flow cell and eliminated
by a light source many cases the laser
lights
gather from the laser usually by
measuring the two angles simultaneously
does n use to discriminate platelets
from red cells and white blood cells the
advantage of the two dimensional
approach is that the resolution between
the platelets and non platelets is not
based on size alone therefore consider
to be more specific
right hand side you can see that there
are two different scatter plots and
different angles of of observation are
made in these two different methods of
optical Plata County
you
this is another diagram of optic
quit accounting in general the low-angle
scatter signal represents volume whereas
the higher angle scatter is derived from
the cellular density in this case
platelets higher angle scattering
represents granulation the diagram on
the left again shows where the impedance
count would indicate the platelet
population the threshold generally
around 33 ventilators and then your non
platelets that would be interfering with
the count on the scatter plot to the
right you'll see the optical plate
account is in the center kind of in a
golden population on platelets are
indicated by the black population
diagram to the right you'll see the
laser light hitting the platelets and
here we actually see the light scatter
in really 360 degrees but the forward
light scatter and wide-angle light
scatter where we're going to detect the
difference between whether it's a play
bit or on the right-hand side whether
it's a red cell and again at the plated
side can see a higher volume of light
scattered and also some manufactures use
a dye that actually stains the platelets
that can be detected at the side angle
scatter area that you can see where it's
either a red or perhaps a green dye
that's next I'd like to speak about the
reference method
the reference method is the most
reliable technology for measuring
platelets as based on the use of
monoclonal antibodies to play that
specific surface antigens international
reference method employs full-color
email fluorescence flow cytometry using
a mixture of two different antibodies BD
41 and CD 61 platelets are identified by
their reaction with these antibodies you
can see from the center diagram and the
plate erythrocyte ratio is determined by
selective gating subsequently
erythrocytes are counted in a separate
hematology analyzer which eventually
allows calculation or play the
concentration based on the scatters that
we see on the right hand side
this ICS ICS H reference methods a to
platform technique as I mentioned which
involves the use of Hematology analyzer
and a flows that commoner and this
cannot be fully automate this fact and
the employment for an experience flow
State comment risk and I've rendered it
difficult to perform the reference
method on a routine basis in hematology
laboratory
there's another single
method available on the market for
immunofluorescent pet accounting using
the monoclonal antibody specifically for
CD 61
in this approach the antibody is
actually freeze-dried into a small
pallet and placed into a tube you can
see in this diagram to the left
packaged in a certain way the tubes can
be taken out and placed next to a dta
tube and put into a sample rack and
process again in about four and a half
to five minutes you will then have an
imino plate account for CD 61
you
here's a clear example of the power of
the immunofluorescent with accounts
they're a single platform approach you
can see by this diagram to take a look
at the lower right corner where it says
Plato though meaning optical plate of
the eye meaning impedance and then CD 61
under the impedance count by looking at
the play that oh and play that ah you
can see that there's interference
looking at the histogram to the right
the impedance plate account is clearly
overlapping into the RVC song
the optical count as well demonstrates
affairs on plate of events located both
above and below that orange or bold
population you take a look at the
results the optical looks 43,000 but it
has a star next to what usually means is
flag them have to be reviewed in this
case this device also does an impedance
plate account and in this case it's
94,000 the truth platelet count is
actually under CD 61 demonstrated by a
to scatter plot spots below that has a
value of 53,000 so in this case it plays
an optical underestimated account
impedance overestimating the count so
you can see the value of the imio plate
account distance
so this to the summarize resolving
playlet population
one dimension approach which is
impedance usually shows cells of only
with the same or similar size as the
separating criteria the overlap
obviously can occur this is we
previously saw on the slide before
two dimensional approach involves using
two angle optical light scatter as we
talked about again you usually can see
their separation however there can be
instances where again they could overlap
and again the three-dimensional approach
would be considered the multiple angle
optical light scatter or floor chrome
tag monoclonal approach in this case
even though there may be some
interferences or similarities it will
ultimately be separated with the floor
chrome tagged monoclonal antibodies
factors affecting plate count the
liability
quality of the plate account may be
susceptible to plate account errors two
primary types of error pre-analytical
errors which could be involved with
sample collection and certainly can
involve plate it bumps and also
analytical errors interference as they
are found based on disease or other
problems such as microsites
justa sites or giant platelets
without lined in this table below
interferences that impact but account
for liability
falsely increasing your plate account
can be a result of red cell
fragmentation extreme microcytic red
cells such as an iron deficiency for
thalassemia microangiopathic analysis
with schistocytes for two firms with
micro scarce items
BBC fragments and compulsory increase
the put account because the fragments
themselves are very difficult to
distinguish from actual play but even
when doing like an estimate
microsites bacteria
area of parasites
aggregates immune complexes and comma
microns can all contribute to falsely
increased platelet counts decrease this
can be included by the clumps such as
DDT a induced platelet aggregation we
call that private neutral style autism
or poor sample quality due to clotting
activated platelets do 2d granulated
platelets and of course abnormal
Plymouth five giant platelets such as in
Bernard Soulier syndrome they had one
anomaly by this blast syndromes central
thrombocytopenia or micro said played it
says and wiskott-aldrich syndrome
RBC's Aslam
classify his platelets in this smear
review you can see on the right hand
side very small red cells rights the
right hand side you can see red cell
schistocytes
in both cases just can impact the type
account those can be generally counted
as platelets by impedance systems and
sometimes can even confuse the optical
product out as well generally speaking
when McD's are less than 60 the
distribution will have some that even
much smaller than 60 and that's why they
may be counted as large plate
WBC fragments can be classified as
planets - if you take a look at the
sphere around the white blood cells and
where the arrows are pointing you can
see these small white blood cell
fragments
and certainly any acute leukemia or high
grades on thumb or malignancy treated
with chemotherapy
these can be a major contributed to
false increase in platelet count
for our right-hand side keep megablast
leukemia one of the key reasons we see
the WBC fragments
to always be alert that overestimation
should be suspected in all case the
malignancy we're pleasant count is
higher than expected
although rare neck rogue and
microorganisms may be responsible for
unreliable pipe accounts this mirror you
can see intracellular platelets or
parasites rather and in that case
sometimes this red cell were to Hima
lies they may become free and they
falsely impact the plate account by
increasing
abnormal proteins may result in an
increased count as well diseases or
factors or abnormal plasma aggregates as
effective let it count and impact many
of the methods especially the impedance
but account conditions associated with
para proteins or cry of proteins and
warming mainly disorders of b-cells and
include lymphomas - myeloma and
macroglobulinemia
David clumps and aggregates are common
cause of falsely decreased plate
accounts we've previously described the
clear review over the right hand side
you can see plate bumps clearly would
decrease your plate account
and play the satellite dosis the right
hand side also be a candidate for
decreasing your plate account
giant plates may be misclassified as
RBC's or excluded from the count
spiraling
the curb primarily in the
myeloproliferative disorders such as the
chronic myeloid leukemia and from Oh
psyche Gnaeus and rare hereditary
disorders it can also be acquired
conditions such as the autoimmunity
Apothic karma Serafina corpora the
migraines empathic hemolytic anemias
conditions are as large as or even
larger than normal red cells and again
in those systems but overlap between the
plated population and the red cell
population
small plates that may be excluded from
the plate account can occur as well such
as wiskott-aldrich syndrome didn't see
how tiny these are generally plates that
fall on the lower threshold of less than
two to three centers and may be
inadvertently excluded from the plate
account so this can be a reason for
again lower count and expect
so what can be the clinical impact
associated with errors in the play that
counts
most important is associated with the
plate account is when the transfusion
decision is to be determined whether to
give pilots or not to give platelets one
of the key provisions here is the plated
count transfusion trigger level
generally most laboratories and
clinicians will look at a level of about
ten thousand that count becomes very
important because obviously at the very
very low level that it is the
interference that we previously saw can
impact that value so let's take it for
example if platelets counts were bless
them the ten thousand they would be
needed with regards to play the
transfusion as given the limit risk of
cerebral bleeding is taken care of
if they're not given certainly the
increased cerebral bleeding can occur
if the platelet count transfusion
trigger is not needed
may cause unwanted clinical effect such
as a transfusion reaction if they're
given again because the erroneous pet
account in too low
and also the expense and unnecessary
waste of plated products as we know
platelets are very expensive and an
inventory standpoint also sensitive keep
on hand
obviously if it's not needed they have a
good count not given there's no no
impact on the patient care
the limitations of different
but accounting methods associated with
transfusion decisions the far right hand
side you can see have labeled suitable
for transfusions decision management and
over on the left hand side they pick
their methods the manual plate account
again because of its interferences based
on types of proteins really do not
impact it nor do interferences from
microsites
for interferences of RBC or WBC
fragments although sometimes the WBC
fragments even the new by our chamber
very hard to distinguish between
platelets but you can count Jane
Clayton's can see those clearly but it
does have a very low level of accuracy
as we previously described and imprecise
at less than 10,000 so when it comes
suitability for transfusion incision
management I would consider it highly
unreliable
he displayed account method
interferences can occur with plasma
proteins and appearances from microsites
RBC WBC fragmentation and of course
ability to count giant platelets no
because if you recall only looking at
theis those are most likely fall into
the red salt window
so it has a low level of accuracy we
would say below 20,000 it's somewhat
reliable but again we recommend
reviewing a snare before any plated
transfusion would be administered
the optical plate account in KL
interferences maybe some plasma proteins
if its aggressive aggregates
sometimes interferences from microsites
and again this can occur if the shift
site of the microsite is is abnormal in
such case that would emulate a play but
most likely this will not a criticism
RBC WBC fragment again occasionally but
again distinguishing the platelets from
the red cells even if they were in
fragmentation form play that is usually
considered denser through the
granulation and will separate from these
account giant platelets again can be
variable
so from a low level of accuracy limited
to about 10,000 or that transfusion
threshold in most most laboratories with
Jews more reliable than impedence but
you still would need to review smear
Corsi Mia played account as we reviewed
there's virtually no interferences we've
seen across most the primary of
interfering substances accurate the way
they are not down to about 1000 and
certainly is the method of choice and is
why the ICS each considers if they
reference methods
so it's summarize what accounts are
particularly important for clinical
decisions on administering plated
products to patients with twelfth
rhombic at opinion most methods for
public counting are not very precise in
the low range their accuracy can be
compromised by the interference as we
described you know analytical
limitations of Plata County may
challenge the lower plated transfusion
threshold of ten thousand again that's
what we have to then make a
determination if there is access to the
immuno flood account as that being the
be approved or the best way to make a
decision for that the transfusion and of
course the technological progress
continues to bring improve but
accounting methods
so at this time I'd like to ask if there
are any questions
the lines and I do appreciate your time
Thank You Donald informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the answer question
box located on the far left of your
screen and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is if
impotence method for platelets is so
prone to problems why are so many
vendors still using this technology
yes impedance technology is robust
nowadays I didn't mean to imply
otherwise in this sense but we must
understand that with intense technology
we do know what interferes with it and
actually that's a positive because when
we do see the interference we know we
need to obviously look at an alternate
technology to validate that particular
account so it's a robust method from an
economic standpoint I'm sure it's well
known and needs to put into systems and
again as I also described in the
presentation you know a lot of the newer
systems have resolved many of the types
of error that occurred in the earlier
systems with using impedance now that
that's such as hydrodynamic focusing
again eliminating any kind of
recirculation problem in 50 the
detection zone so it didn't mean to
imply that it is a bad method in any way
whatsoever it's actually like I said
quite robust and if anything when you
have an error you will have an error and
you know that you have an interference
that is present at that the particular
sampling needs to be resolved so I hope
that helps to clarify that
next question right next yes we have
cellavision in our lab what do you think
of the performance of the platelet count
estimation verse other methods
you
television and like they would probably
approach all digital morphology type
systems is I think the key word in your
question is plated estimation as we know
these are not devices that have been
necessarily cleared some may have for
that account but it takes a great deal
to obviously come up with an algorithm
that's extremely accurate as compared to
doing an actual fixed solution on a
whole blood sample and then counting it
in a event by event of clear
distributional advantage method that
gives you the event per event based on
the pollution ratio so in that sense you
know you're you're subject to an old
digital morphology quality the smear and
of course if there's any issues with
regards to making that smear that can
also jeopardize or compromise your your
estimate that you're getting but again
finestatt it's based on pure statistic
two numbers of events that you can
actually evaluate um I'm sure they do a
great job and almost to give you a good
estimate of what you're doing this goes
you would be able to do perhaps maybe
better as an individual sitting down
microscopically reviewing the field but
still just the same it's not like
actually getting a good number of a high
number of events when you have an
automated approach to it
so download our next question is on
slide 19 where you mentioned that
platelets and RBC's show unique
signatures using multi dimensional
analysis can you describe more about
what you mean by the unique signatures
yes again as we have evolved and
Counting and evaluating platelets from
automated methods obviously as I did in
the kind of dimensional overview of
looking at just sighs it's been a great
asset than counting accuracy and giving
us the values that we could actually use
from a clinical standpoint but when it
comes to again interferences this is the
the prime objective of almost any areas
and science platelets is to try to
resolve as many of those interferences
we possibly can so the evolution of
optical play that analysis did give us
what we felt another dimension to being
able to resolve some of the problems
that occur especially if you have two
events of the same size and impedance
obviously picked you know a rather
strong algorithm to try to decipher what
that is and if it is truly an
interference or just part of the play
that RBC populations so the difference
between platelets and our DTS obviously
there are some physical characteristics
that we can take advantage of when
looking at them optically or again by
other methods as I suggested but the
immuno plate account the primary assists
obviously
let's have granules red cells generally
don't they shouldn't and they have
hemoglobin and platelets don't so if we
can take advantage of some of those
intracellular characteristics and
perhaps we can get another dimension of
being able to define each one of those
signals into two distinct event so with
that being said when we get into more
additional or approaches again the
definitive is using the monoclonal
antibodies that are sensitive to the two
b3a sites of glycoproteins and the
platelets that's the that's the ultimate
but again as I mentioned it's it's not
practical to do one of those a long time
so where we need to look at a practical
approach you know against that we're
evolving using perhaps more angles of
light together that could give us that
or different dyes that can give us more
information be more definitive in fossa
I'm the red stuff in the plated week do
you have the interfering for and more
importantly those that maybe have the
same side
I have heard there's a
by SAR stead for pseudo thrombocytopenia
do you have any information on this tube
or what can it do for the lab
I mean I've heard about it I have not
worked with it so all I know is from
this standpoint we know that there is a
situation more EDTA
sensitivity from individuals can cause
platelets li ptosis around white cells
neutrophils in particular and when we
see that obviously we know we have a
decreased plate account so again I
emphasize you know very important to
make sense out of your results always
cross-check look to see what there is
and obviously if there is a decreased
platelet count you know you would and
should do a scan or review of this smear
this particular tube from I understand
obviously uses the alternate to EDTA so
that would eliminate the sensitivity to
that in supposedly it would cut down or
eliminate supposedly the the plate of
sensitive EDTA satellite ISM and that
would be a good thing but again you'd
have to probably do a redraw in that
case and then perhaps then rerun that
sample
is there any procedure to avoid platelet
clump for accurate platelet count
just as again mentioned in the
presentation this is obviously a
pre-analytical issue most of the time
and it does evolve involved rather you
know just taking your precautions and
following the appropriate technique for
phlebotomy when you're drawing any type
of samples as we know is sometimes when
the samples not mix correctly if on a
drawing and other factors that can be
involved with the creating the by the
clot but pretty much I think if you
follow the appropriate the techniques in
in phlebotomy we can avoid a lot of
those mixing well after blood has been
drawn and all the other you know
precautions that you should take
other than that I am NOT a advocate of
if there is a sample that's received a
laboratory and you do see clots I know
some laboratories do try to remove those
claws by agitation or something related
to that
the vortexing etc I just think if it
create more problems than then you start
out with aside from that perhaps
requesting a new sample I know that's
more difficult for the patient and
sometimes the patient's and outpatient
this is very hard to get that sample
back in but I think you know again most
laboratories have a standard operating
procedure set up to to to manage that
so Donald our next question how do you
estimate platelets with a low hematocrit
[Music]
the cult and more importantly as you do
have to consider you're doing a plated
estimate that you have your microscopic
factors suggested appropriately for your
samples that have anemia and again I
think if you look at any of the techs on
how to conduct an appropriate you know
plated estimate the you know describes
and it is painful as a matter of fact
and if you have even two different
manufacturers of microscopes each one of
those should have different the factor
involved when it when it's regarding how
many play this per field you should be
spotting because obviously the
objectives may be different so it's just
a matter of making sure that you've done
enough of your pre work to assure that
your factors are good and robust enough
and also you've done in your studies and
have documentation for your factor
analysis that you've done some with
those that have anemia and very little
hematocrit so it's just part of your
setup we're doing an accurate by that
estimate
now what is the principle behind CD 61
in able to eliminate platelet clumps
interference
CD sixty-one process will not actually
eliminate playback pumped if Plato
clumps are found you're going to
actually probably in the one single
platform I discussed will be actually
flags that come up and still indicate
there's play the pump but what it can do
is that if there are schistocytes or
other interferences that could resemble
platelets or other types of
interferences maybe white blood cell
fragmentation fragments those are very
very difficult to resolve and certainly
the 61 and or 41 reference method would
be very specific it is very specific
with platelets and and all other
interferences are eliminated the one
thing it would not eliminate if you had
plated clumps it would attach to the
clump and be very bright and would
probably trigger would most likely
trigger a flag that you have excesses
while large platelets in it and you
would still have to request a new sample
so Donald you stated that immuno
platelet is unable to count giant
platelet why
was that question one more time please
of course so the question is you stated
that immuno platelets is unable to count
giant platelets why
that's not true I don't think I said
that Amino plate account can count diet
plates
the other methods so in the market which
could be again some optical again the
impedance and those are the ones that
are more difficult to count those who
will have some sort of a flag due to
overlap but if again you know any type
of macro six homicides present you know
it will have the appropriate lack of
protein sights to adhere to CD 61 so
that if that was understood in that
manner that I apologize
perhaps maybe want to correct that but
the amino plated well count giant plate
effectively more so than any other
method on the market the other thing to
you'll recall on the table I also
indicated that you know one of the
interesting things certainly your your
estimate will help with giant plates as
well as doing an annual count which is
very rarely done anymore those giant buy
this can be seen this ball in those but
the amino play that can and will
effectively count giant places
all right so our next question it looks
like what methods exist for detecting
immature platelets
I didn't touch on the immature platelets
so much but the obviously the method
methods on the market today
usually evolved some sort of nucleic
acid dye and the immature play-doh dose
obviously has residual RNA and with
these particular stains or dyes that are
intrinsic within the reagent systems do
stain those and when you do a plate
account in this manner you're looking
for fluorescent and the amount of
fluorescence is directly proportional to
the amount of RNA residual it's in that
particular platelet in from that we can
actually begin to regular understand you
know the amount of immature plated
production that is present in a
particular sample again one of the
problems with the immature reticulocyte
farms are the immature plated a fraction
is there are no standards yet in the
industry there's probably the controls
are an optimize at this point it's not
really a excellent analogue that would
cost all the technologies and methods
that are out there that it exists so
you're you're going to have to buy by
the manufacturer that you're using
currently as your source and reference
range approach to how you establish that
in your laboratory there has been and
there is I believe ongoing discussions
in the ICS H international council for
Standardization hematology to obviously
find means and ways to find standards
for such things as the immature play
that fraction as well as even the
immature pretzel reticulocyte fraction
because those are still again more
technology dependent so those are still
challenges that have to be resolved in
the future
Donald in your opinion what would be the
next key breakthrough an automatic
platelet counting technology to advance
the field other than more angles of
light scatter
I think there's one approach that
obviously has proven itself to be the
most robust and that would be the immuno
platelet count and two things of
breakthrough would would have to occur I
think there have to be a reduction in
cost of the monoclonal itself to make it
more practical to reflect whenever you
had any type of flag associated with a
platelet count on an automated system it
is a reference method so in hematology
we don't work in the same environment
the chemistry does where you can go in
and plot a standard and calibrate a
system to a reference standard and we
don't have that Nemeth ology except for
one and that would be the immuno
platelet count so if we could get the
cost down and have that in a platform
that could obviously deliver that in a
completely automated fashion I think
that would be one of the most exciting
stuff there is as far as accuracy goes
and certainly I think help the clinician
in many ways knowing that their plate
account which they always believe
everything is perfect from the
laboratory and I laugh at that but from
a laboratory in standpoint we always
know we have the absolute best bit
account that we could deliver to the
clinician
you
with regard to platelet transfusions is
there any research underway that you
know you know of to produce artificial
platelets that could be used in a human
transfusion
um what we've looked at and if worked
with some companies and there are
diplomatic type of artificial play that
that's been worked on for probably I'd
say ten plus years this doesn't seem to
have resolved into a commercial product
or evolved in a commercial product at
this point I'm aware of also the
approach of taking platelets human
platelets in by authorizing them and
packing them so they have extended
shelf-life from a cost standpoint to be
used in remote areas where it's hard to
obviously transport the product of
liquid product you have to remote areas
and a lie off lies product might be the
next step in the evolution platelet
transfusion again one of these things
how far we away from a synthetic product
it's very difficult you know many areas
of Medicine have been trying to use
synthetic products whether it be RBC's
would it be any type of joint
replacements and things they definitely
have their drawbacks and some have not
achieved any clinical success so I think
we're a little ways away yet but I do
see some of these other products that
come in coming up in research that may
be good alternatives
we've gotten so many good questions
today but it looks like we only have
time for one more wire platelet levels
so high in pediatric patients less than
a year old
excellent question and there are several
publications out there and it's pretty
well known that the obviously
thrombopoietin is a primary regulator of
mega karaoke system play the production
and it's pretty well established at tpo
concentrations in kind of a non
thrombocytopenic preterm and term
infants is significantly higher than in
healthy adults so with that being said
it's it's important that your reference
ranges are set appropriately so
clinicians don't overreact or more
importantly they're not looking at adult
ranges which could then make them have
caused to obviously consider other types
of of diseases or or again continue to
test or something that may not back be
not either so with respect to that I
think it's important to again establish
your knee innate and pediatric reference
ranges to manufacturers system that
you're working with and obviously have
this posted you know in the laboratory
and making sure that those are also in
your in your results page whenever those
are reported out
thank you again Donald do you have any
final comments for our audience
well again I appreciate you know your
attendance today and certainly the topic
of play this will be with us for many
years to come and hopefully we can
continue to improve on the accuracy of
these these reports and the the ability
to comfort its day in all diseases and
eventually get to the point of
eliminating interferences has been a
problem with with the accounting you
know I have a lot of hope that we can
get to that point I think we have some
methods out there that could potentially
get us there and certainly I think it's
still a very important topic because
obviously we have a variety of different
systems out there so most importantly is
so if you question something always
confirm it with the sneer and so a
strong believer and human identification
of detection of disease
thank you and I appreciate your time
today
before
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today or those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of the registration we would like
to thank laberd's and our sponsor Abbott
Diagnostics for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through December of
2018 labret salute you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye
and works